hey from family we only have one more
episode left and things are going
absolutely crazy and from town and if I
have to hear one more person say we're
all going to die I'm going to shoot
myself that's right we're almost at the
end but there is still so much to talk
about for those of you new to these
videos this is not a recap rather a
breakdown of all the new theories
Mysteries and clues from the latest
episode I've left timestamps below so
you can see all the topics I'll be
covering now secure your talismans night
is upon us the last episode left us with
Reggie screaming for help you may
remember he and Paula took over Sarah's
place after she murdered her brother
Paula has seemingly been killed from the
inside out with Reggie claiming that
something cracked from within her but
before she died she kept repeating the
same thing over and over again in her
sleep the same rhyme Kenny heard at the
beginning of episode 8. they touch they
break they steal no one here is free
this is our first confirmation of a
death via sleep previously Elgin and
Kenny had experiences of their dreams
creeping into the real world but nothing
to this extent and I gotta say Paula's
body looks mutilated just like how the
monsters would kill their victims the
nursery rhyme is also what Elgin
remembers from his dream he spent most
of the Season trying to remember what it
was and only when Fatima tells him that
she's pregnant does it trigger something
inside of him Elgin however tells them
it was a boy dressed in white who said
this rhyme which leads me to believe
it's the boy in white from season one
now if you go to IMDb the actor who
plays him is credited as being in the
season 2 finale but take that with a
grain of salt because IMDb can often be
wrong from what we know the boy in white
seems to be a good character helping
Boyd and Sarah at the end of season one
if he's saying this rhyme it's likely a
clue to help them last episode we saw a
swarm of cicadas hovering over the dead
body of smile finally only to disappear
a few moments later in this episode
they've become a legitimate threat
almost every scene Outdoors you can hear
them but we can't be sure that these
cicadas are real Marielle sees them but
Christy doesn't Julie is seemingly
attacked by them but no one else can see
them Randall 2 is attacked but he's the
only one out there so we can't be
certain if that's in his head or not I'm
also curious if this is the last time
we'll see Randall I doubt it because we
see Mariel and Julie attacked and they
still seem to be alive we also see these
cicadas enter into his mouth and it
makes me wonder if Randall might come
back as one of those monsters after all
with smiley dead does the town need
someone new to take his place Sarah also
posits an interesting theory about the
insects stating that her brother Nathan
thought cicadas were monsters what if
the fears of the people who died here
became part of the forest I don't 100
buy this yet but it is something
interesting to think about now Marielle
and Julie are by these cicadas but it
appears only they can see them
marielle's eyes turn gray and is put
into this sort of catatonic state it can
be assumed then that Julie and Randall
will end up this way too I wonder if
they'll have a limited amount of time to
save them before they turn into that
woman from the beginning of the episode
you may have also seen that winter is
coming we can see our character's breath
in the cold weather a few episodes ago
we learned from Victor that the town had
been in a Perpetual state of Summer but
something has changed this seems to have
started with the death of Martin leaving
no bodies chained up in that building
Boyd found in episodes one and two if
you haven't seen my video last week I go
into full detail about how the nursery
rhyme connects to three of our
characters Kenny Elgin and Marielle and
to these three chain prisoners from
earlier in the season but with Mariel
Julie and Randall being sworn by cicadas
maybe this mysterious power has other
plans not only has the weather changed
but Sarah notes that the town feels
different now that it feels wrong
stating that it feels like how the
forest did when she and Boyd traveled
there far away something seems to have
been holding a darker Force at Bay from
the town but now all bets are off
something needs to change and it appears
the nursery rhyme is the clue Midway
through the episode we see Boyd cover
his bullets in Smiley's bile with the
theory that since this bile was mixed
with the worms that killed Smiley maybe
it will kill the other monsters too but
it doesn't look like that's the case
we'll see Boyd shoots several of the
monsters and it seems to have no effect
it'll be disappointing if this bile
amounts to nothing perhaps it could be
used to cure Mariel Julia Randall and
just a reminder if you like these types
of videos be sure to like And subscribe
every little bit helps the channel the
episode is titled ball of magic fire a
reference to Ellison Christie's chat
about how easy We Believe crazy things
if they become common if you think about
it the idea of birth is crazy a totally
new person is Created from seemingly
nothing thing but since it happened so
frequently we don't think about it the
same is true with the ball of magic fire
known as our sun our planet hurdles tens
of thousands of miles per hour through
space around a giant ball of fire that's
insane yet we perceive it as normal it
becomes a metaphor for the crazy things
in the town itself they seem crazy but
become normal this meshes with Jade's
chaos theory that he mentioned last
episode while every weird thing that
happens in town may seem disconnected
it's all part of a beautiful plan this
episode also provides some more insight
into Eloise's drawings last episode we
learned that Victor had a sister who
drew pictures that came from stories her
mother used to tell some of the pictures
include an angry large person with happy
people around it a far away tree a
person perhaps a monster coming through
a doorway and a happy person here while
everyone else is sad Jade also
recognizes the Civil War soldiers he saw
back in season one does that mean that
Victor's mom's stories are somehow
manifesting in real life Victor will
later recite something his mom used to
say that everything is a story and we're
the ones who get to decide How It Ends
the most important drawing however seems
to be this one of the lighthouse
something Boyd and Sarah saw at the end
of season one Tabitha has also had
dreams about this Lighthouse combine
this with her being haunted by ghost
children she's finally clued in that
maybe these children need her help after
all Victor said his mother was off to
the lighthouse to save the children only
when they're saved can they make it out
of town one of the things I like about
Victor but is also frustrating is that
I'm never sure if he knows more than
he's letting on he'll tell Ethan that a
mass killing event like what happened to
him as a child won't happen again is he
merely trying to ease Ethan's fears or
does he know something that we don't the
music box is at it again or should I say
it's Melody over the radio while Boyd
Donna Jim and Randall are cooped up in
the RV it seems to hold the monsters at
Bay but as we learn from Martin in
episode 2 once the Music Stops bad
things happen there's also the added WTF
moment of banging coming from beneath
them how is that even possible there's
nothing there if that wasn't crazy
enough we have Boyd's dead wife making a
visit telling him to quote come back to
me this would imply she wants Boyd to
die so they can be together Sarah is fed
up with life and plays a game of Russian
Roulette this is clearly a woman who's
on the edge and I wouldn't be surprised
if she does something drastic next
episode was her surviving the gun luck
or did whatever powers that be have a
hand and lastly I want to bring up Tilly
and how she somehow knew Fatima was
pregnant this isn't the first time Tilly
has known something that was a secret
she knew in episode 4 that Boyd had been
on a quote unquote Adventure but it's
possible she could have learned that
from another towns person I think
something is up with her I don't know
what but I got my eyes on you Tilly
those are all the big topics I wanted to
cover so now I turn over to you what do
you think will happen in the season
finale leave your thoughts and theories
in the comments below be sure to like
And subscribe and for more bad takes you
can follow me on Twitter and Instagram
at thinkstory YT until next time
remember
everybody